13 6
bueno vamos a iniciar movimiento táctico
motorizado desde el puesto de mando en
saravena
ya movimiento que son eso
los riesgos que se pueden presentar en
esta zona es la instalación de
artefactos explosivos sobre la vía
en colombia todavía hay guerra en
saravena en el oriental departamento de
arauca 78 personas han sido asesinadas
desde enero es un municipio de 43 mil
personas la tasa de homicidios por
100.000 habitantes es de 181 si se
mantiene la proyección de asesinatos
sería una de las tasas más altas del
mundo dos guerrillas el ejército de
liberación nacional y las disidencias de
las extintas farc luchan por el control
del territorio
estas son las instalaciones del
instituto colombiano agropecuario de
sarabela y neil caminas sobre las ruinas
en las que su padre trabajaba como
guardia de seguridad aquí el 19 enero
exactamente a las 10 35 de la noche un
carro bomba explotó en la parte del
frente del icap un atentado terrorista
hacia el edificio que se encontraba al
lado fue la respuesta de las disidencias
a las decenas de homicidios selectivos
cometidos presuntamente por el ln a
principios de año en medio del conflicto
también quedan los civiles como simeón
delgado
una manera
en colombia hay más de 9 millones de
víctimas después de cinco décadas de
conflicto el del inei es el dolor de la
guerra mi papá quedó totalmente
la bomba iba dirigida contra este
edificio
sirve de casa para distintas
organizaciones sociales como la
fundación joel sierra el principal
objetivo de las disidencias de las farc
los acusan de colaborar con el ln y si
quiere someter nosotros desde la
fundación de derechos humanos también
contamos con el servicio de una
psicóloga el día de la bomba les
avisaron de que algo iba a pasar unos 60
líderes estaban en el edificio la
dirección que tomó la onda expansiva les
salvó como pueden ver con nuestros
propios esfuerzos se ha logrado al menos
de esto medio a avanzar en en
acomodarnos un poquito porque el daño
fue gravísimo a esta estructura la
fundación trabaja en la defensa de los
derechos humanos una profesión de riesgo
desde la firma del acuerdo de paz de
2016 entre el estado y las farc más de
1300 líderes sociales han sido
asesinados en colombia
porque fue un día que intentaron borrar
los de la faz de la tierra
un día yo creo que seguimos nosotros
estamos haciendo las cosas bien porque
intentaron matarnos
estos son los tanques de almacenamiento
donde convergen este grueso es el
oleoducto bicentenario
y el delgado que vamos a ver al lado de
allá es el oleoducto caño limón-coveñas
para que es rica en recursos como el
petróleo
a pocos kilómetros de saravena el
ejército custodia con más de 40 hombres
sus dos oleoductos bien bueno me alegra
muy bien gracias por el trabajo que
realizan en caño limón sellaron dos mil
millones de barriles de petróleo en 1983
colombia pasó a ser un país exportador y
empezó la bonanza petrolera
hoy arauca genera el 7 por ciento del
crudo del país
este ha sido fuente de financiación para
los grupos armados de ahí los múltiples
enfrentamientos con la fuerza pública
miedo no no siento miedo no yo creo que
uno siempre va acompañado de dios soy
muy apegado a dios y desde que uno tenga
la protección de ese ser
glorioso que está desde arriba
protegiéndonos vamos bien
jorge eduardo mora es el mayor general
que controla la octava división
la mayor de colombia él es el quinto en
la línea de mando
como lo habíamos
esta mañana vamos a a
desde yopal casanare departamento
fronterizo con arauca controla todo lo
que pasa en el oeste del país y está la
brigada 18 en arauca eso es
prácticamente
todo el campo de combate de arauca el
mayor general jorge eduardo morán
muestra una sala de guerra eso esos tres
pilares de contener proteger y atacar
las áreas bases sus campamentos sus
cabecillas nos ha dado los grandes
resultados operacionales en medio del
conflicto armado que vivimos nosotros
los jóvenes le apostamos a la cultura y
le apostamos a salir adelante y en cañas
está harta de los estigmas como que
llamen a su pueblo sara bomba en su
lucha organiza este evento de cultura al
parque con emprendimientos y música
en una armonía
ya podemos ir logrando por medio del
diálogo intermedio
a pesar de la guerra los araucanos se
vuelcan en el evento después de décadas
de conflicto se acostumbraron a no
acostumbrarse
hago lo necesario para terminar